what's not depressing is the holiday
movie season which is now here this
means blockbusters family films and time
to consider which movies might win
awards one of the seasons most
anticipated openings is what is that
some movie called star the last Jedi the
latest installment the sci-fi franchise
is reportedly projected to earn 200
million dollars in its first weekend
when it opens December 15th slate film
critic Dana Stevens in new york times
culture reporter milena rising are here
good morning to you both good morning
good to be here let's talk Star Wars
I've been talking about it all morning
walk during the commercial breaks how
big is this movie expected to be I think
it's fair to say it's gonna be huge
would you say Dana yeah I mean I think
it's a movie that's attracting even
people out if there are such a thing
people that are outside the Star Wars
fandom I mean it's one that I think
people have been looking forward to for
a long time we know why a superfan would
want to go see it but for a non super
fan who has not been talking about this
during the breaks a fan what's in it for
me okay
well I'll make the pitch so the director
of this movie Rian Johnson is a really
interesting indeed director who people
are excited to see get into this
franchise because I think he could bring
some really original ideas to it and
whatever he's doing they're happy enough
with it that they've now assigned him
another entire Star Wars Star Wars
trilogy after after this movie so you're
say she ating the older kids right but
what about the younger ones I'm thinking
of taking my five-year-old to see koko
over the weekend Pixar's Coco it's
getting some good reviews I think
generally well in Mexico correct yeah
join the club I mean it's definitely
gonna be the top movie this week when
you look at a Pixar movie you know at
the end of the year box office lists
these movies are always at the top of
the chain so they're doing something
right in terms of attracting new
audiences with a movie that's set in a
Mexican cultural world so let's talk
about Jumanji there's a reboot of
Jumanji which of course started Robin
Williams in the original it's also
coming out why this one I mean this one
seems interesting to me and that it
takes the original Jumanji idea which is
that you can jump into a board game and
become part of the game into the digital
era
so there's kids who jump into a video
game and become their avatars so in fact
I think there's a 12 year old kid who
becomes the rock
Dwayne the rock Johnson though very
different from Robin Williams and how's
that gonna change the way the film plays
I think you've got somebody like Kevin
Hart in the movie as well so you have
that kind of buddy comedy aspect that's
what they're probably banking on and
let's move to Steven Spielberg to the
post of course it's about the Pentagon
paper starring Tom Hanks Meryl Streep
given the political environment we're in
right now do you think it's gonna bring
more people to this movie than it would
have otherwise well it's an interesting
question I mean are people gonna turn
out for it or are they gonna want to
break I think from the political angle
it's a very timely movie and I think it
hopefully will find its fans you know it
could be the kind of movie that
spotlight was a couple years ago where
it attracts people who are interested in
the news interested in these ideas and
it's definitely one to watch during
Oscar season Dana there's a drama called
call me by your name and you're
describing it as the great date movie of
the winter a movie you want to not just
watch but live in yeah I'm glad we got
to because it's a little smaller maybe
more of an art house offering but it's
great it's it's a gay romance it's
directed by an Italian director named
Luca Guadagnino and it takes place in in
Italy in the summer so if you want to go
and get sort of some you know some
bottled summer in the middle of winter
it's just a beautiful languorous
romantic film I can get into that works
for me milena I'm curious because the
last time you were here we were talking
about sexual scandals and in Hollywood
and I'm curious just psychologically how
important is this box-office season for
Hollywood given all of the scandals and
the turmoil that we've been covering
over the past you know a few months your
your paper in particular unfolding a lot
of the scandal yeah well when you talk
about award season there is gonna be a
sort of elephant missing in the room
which is The Weinstein Company and those
kind of movies they were known for their
Oscar campaigns that's not going to be
in evidence this year but I think in
terms of box office I mean Hollywood is
always looking for a great holiday
season especially since they haven't had
you know an excellent year overall with
a few notable exceptions like Wonder
Woman but you know Star Wars is gonna
bring us back the post is gonna be that
sort of thinking persons movie so I
think they will probably wrap up well in
cocoa for me tomorrow
cocoa for you you guys
on me right Antonio see call me by your
name but you should go see Star Wars I'm
sure cake Danny Molina thank you so much
thank you being here